turn it back on to the same song you
screwed up man I gotta get back in the
groove specifically the New York groove
give me my Zune no give me the zoom give
it commands since this song it's a
degenerate I will not sit here and allow
you to malign Ace Frehley give me this
is not helping we haven't even looked
yet
me seize the moment you trying to kill
us he said I'd be saving the universe
would kill either of you if it would
stop that blinking yellow light the
coded message channel was just been on
mantis a blinking yellow light indicates
an important secret coded message shame
on you man how long this was your job it
was his job Jax
you didn't see the blinking yellow light
did but you said if it was yellow let it
Mellow brown flush it down those were
your orders wasn't talking about the
Cody the message
22 important coded secret messages that
could have been helpful five hours
I've been sitting five hours we have 22
messages 23 messages oh I keep coming in
from nebula Kimura is alive danos is
taking her to Titan why aren't you
responding why aren't you responding
are you getting my important coded
secret messages ship coordinates
how do we know this isn't a trap hey
everybody its charlie infinity war is
dropping on digital this week so
naturally all kinds of bonus features
are dropping you can probably tell just
from watching this why they decided to
cut it out if you're brand new to the
channel there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video this is
just the beginning we have bloopers we
have a whole bunch more deleted scenes
and behind the scenes stuff that'll be
posting in the next couple of days but
you can see that there are a couple of
plot beats during this the contradict
with the actual final plot of the movie
ended up being so it just like the
process of making a movie this big where
you shoot way more footage than you
actually need so it gives you a good
idea for what the original story was
before they sort of changed the script
depending on what the final edit is that
usually what happens in reshoots like
after they put in edit of the film
together like okay this is what our
rough cut is gonna look like
we cut a bunch of stuff out so we have
to re-record some dialogues so that all
the pieces work together so you probably
spotted a couple of the easter eggs
during this - not just the poop jokes
tracks always on point with his jokes
when star-lord yells at him to turn the
song back on he's playing ace freelee's
New York groove which is from his first
solo album in 1978 because all of the
Guardian songs in the trilogy you know
including guardians 3 are centered
around 70s films like the ship that
they're on is called the Benatar
somebody was arguing with the producers
why it would be called the Benatar when
Pat Benatar was known more for her 80s
stuff but the way they justify the name
is is it because she did record stuff
during the 70s so any song that you hear
on mixtape 3.0 in guardians 3 is gonna
be a 70s song but you see how they move
through the 70s decade throughout the
film so like in guardians 1 a lot of the
songs were from the earlier 70s
guardians to mid 70s infinity war were
pushing into the late 70s so all the
final mixtape 3.0 guardians 3 songs will
be from the late 70s they're using yondu
Zune from the end of guardians to
[Music]
captain found this free and a junker
shop said you can come back to the boat
someday
listen it's called a Zune it's what
everybody's listening to on earth
nowadays got 300 songs on it 300 songs
will call that mixtape 2.5 because it's
not an actual physical tape and I think
the guardians mixtapes need to be actual
cassette tapes the funny thing about
yondu 2 is that he actually showed up in
a thor ragnarok deleted scene probably
one of the best ones because it was so
unexpected you know where Kevin and Lu's
offices are no oh thanks man go ahead 4c
they were filming the scene where Hellas
on Asgard starting to execute the
Asgardians but they were shooting on a
stage that was nearby where Michael
Rooker was shooting some yondu scenes
for something different that Disney was
doing so he was in full yondu makeup
near where they were shooting thor
ragnarok stuff so he just walked onto
the Ragnarok set in Tyco what TD is like
hey you know what we're shooting this
special scene here why don't you just
walk right in like it's no big deal so
if you were confused by why yondu just
showed up mysteriously on Asgard while
all this craziness with hello was going
on during Ragnarok it was just because
Michael Rooker was in makeup shooting
Guardians stuff nearby it had nothing to
do with the actual plot of the movies
but Drax just can't handle any more that
New York crew because as they explained
star-lord has been stuck sitting on no
we're not sure what to do next after the
nose took Gamora so this is all
happening after nebula escaped so it
gives you an idea for how quickly
thinness is moving less than 5 hours
between him taking Gamora back to
sanctuary to having that long
conversation with her torturing nebula
then go
to tighten by way of or mere to get the
soul stone
so maybe nebula thought that he would
bring Gamora back to Titan after they
got the soul stone she didn't really
understand about the sacrifice that was
necessary you had to love Drax as logic
in this to blaming star-lord because
they didn't allow Drax to attack Thanos
in this moment here before mantas put
the Whammy on him you had to assume that
had star-lord successfully killed Gamora
as she had asked and made that sacrifice
that Thanos would not have been able to
find the soul stone right away he may
have been able to get it eventually but
there was this unspoken plotline during
the movie whereby Thanos had to collect
all six of the stones before the forces
of the universe learned what he was
doing that's why he was moving so
quickly like they say five hours between
this moment and Thanos making it back to
Titan width the soul stone in tow the
other funny thing about this is that
they're talking about this yellow
warning light that's going off that
neither Drax nor mantas has been paying
attention to you can clearly see that
it's flashing green as we get more of
these bonus features I'll do new videos
for them in the next couple of days but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
just a reminder to the Deadpool to
blu-ray is gonna be dropping later this
summer too so we'll get like all the
deleted scenes all the crazy stuff from
Deadpool in a couple more weeks
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last big video random
black gamer please email me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to learn
about Disney getting all those x-men and
Fantastic Four characters and click here
for that immortal weapons iron fist
fight scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]